Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Factorio with Bob. Hi Bob!
Bob: Hey, how's it going?
Mark: We're doing good!
Mark: I don't mean to speak for you, Bob. Bob: we got all sorts of stuff goin' on
Mark: I don't know if you're doing good or not. I just want to assume we are doing okay.
Bob: It's going well, man. Why would it not be going well?
Mark: I don't know, you know, just in, in consideration of everybody, I just didn't want to speak for you.
Mark: Anyway, so this down here is the level 1 factory.
Mark: It looks like it is choking on gears, so
Mark: we probably need this on gears as well.
Bob: No, it's not!
Mark: It's lacking gears.
Bob: Oh, there's not enough gears!
Mark: And we do eventually need more iron and copper funneling into these machines
Mark: but that's fine because we got plenty of science.
Mark: We're, we're currently trying to get flight and shit going on
Mark: Which is like the main thing that we are going for next.
Bob: Should I take down all of my production stuff so I can stop staring at it?
Mark: Yesssssss....no, no, it's like a legacy! Leave it there!
Mark: It's important for us to remember.
Bob: Look how far we have come!
Mark: That one made 37 science!
Bob: Yeah, I just got science out of that. Look at that. LOOK AT THAT!
Mark: It, it works! Bob: how bout that?
Mark: And, you know.....
Mark: It's pretty good.
Bob: It's technically making science!
Mark: And I don't know why this guardian wall is still here
Mark: when all the very important, very delicate assembly machines are all on the outside of the wall
Bob: Yeah, that wall is no longer really appropriate or useful.
Mark: It's protecting history
Mark: like this is a history museum.
Bob: This is our historic district.
Mark: Whoa, I didn't - I didn't have any part of this place.
Bob: See how dumb it is? That is how you can tell it's historic.
Mark: (laughing)
Mark: It's dumb and old and stupid, just like the people that made it.
Mark: Dumb, old, and stupid.
Bob: Aren't you older than me?
Mark: Am I? Yeah, probably by a little bit.
Mark: June 28th? I'm turning 27 June 28th.
Mark: Yeah, you, you, your birthday's later in the year.
Both: October
Mark: So, don't ask me what day! Bob: Oh god!
Bob: Oh God. Mark: What happened?
Bob: Uhh....nothing.
Mark: Were we under attack?
Bob: I ruined my highly functional, um...
Bob: assembly line for a moment there.
Mark: Noooooooo! Bob: would have been a tragedy Mark: Okay, alright, so
Bob: I know, right?
Mark: so I say what we should do next is we should go down
Mark: and show these bastards
Mark: they shouldn't mess with our land!
Bob: Sounds good, sounds good!
Mark: Right? Maybe? I don't know how effective I'm going to be when I am lagging all over the place
Mark: but we're gonna go down there
Mark: and we're gonna kick some ass!
Bob: Are you sure the have....oops, I broke everything again. Hang on.
Mark: God damnit, stop breaking everything.
Bob: It's not my fault. I'm just stupid.
Mark: It sounds exactly like your fault.
Bob: It all connects!
Mark: Niiiiiice.
Bob: I just walled myself out.
(both laugh)
Mark: Bob, no! Oh God, Bob!
Bob: (sarcastically) Mark, how will I ever get back inside the wall?
Mark: You're gone. You're probably already infected. Oh geez!
Bob: Fixed it
Mark: Oh, never mind then.
Mark: Hey!
Bob: Come here!
Mark: No. I'm going to go over here where the aliens are.
Mark: Alright, so what we're gonna do is  we're gonna go over to this alien bastard encampment
Mark: and we're gonna blow the shit out of their faces.
Bob: I say we should, like, bring a turret with us or something.
Mark: I got a turret. Did you not bring a turret?
Bob: I'm going to build my own while we are walking over there.
Mark: Alright, good man-! Good plan!
Mark: We'll formulate it on route.
Bob: Good man! Good plan. Good man plan, man.
Mark: Good plan, man!
Mark: Okay, so there's a lot of - I see a lot of movement.
Bob: I like that we are doing this at night. This feels like a good strategy.
Mark: Yeah, probably the best strategy.
Mark: We're gonna kill these assholes dead.
Mark: Are they coming for us? I can't even tell.
Bob: I, I don't... Mark: I'm gonna place a turret, like, right here
Mark: As the fallback.
Bob: I'll place mine a little bit to the north of you.
Mark: No, place it closer. We're going to try to inch closer to these....
Mark: These assholes.
Bob: Oh, ok. So we'll have leapfrogging bases of attack? Mark: Yeaah
Mark: So it, it's just a small one
(yelling in fear)
Mark: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine!
Mark: Oh God! Oh God, I'm lagging, I'm lagging...Ok, it's fine.
Mark: See? Everything was fine.
Mark: I'm still shooting at nothing.
Mark: Everything's fine.
Mark: Alright, so now....
Bob: Alright, I'm gonna move your turret up closer now
Bob: and, so we can have a little bit of a
Bob: leapfrog scenario going on here
Mark: Okay, cool.
Mark: Alright, I can fire upon the enemy!
Mark: I'm firing upon the enemy
Bob: Attack!
Mark: Attack!
Mark: And see, it dies!
Bob: Have at you!
Bob: Oh God!
Mark: Come at me, bros!
Mark: And then, see? Alien artifacts!
Mark: And you pick them up, and that's goo!
Mark: So now....
Bob: I've got 5 alien artifacts!
Mark: Well done!
Mark: Alright, I pick up mine! Ooo, an electric engine finished!
Bob: I'm gonna research flight!
Mark: NIIIIIIICE!
Mark: Flight means we'll get
Bob: I like how we can
Mark: Huh?
Bob: ....decide what we are gonna research from way the hell far away
Bob: Like, *imitating talking to somebody far away*
HEY, RESEARCH FLIGHT, GUYS!
(laughing)
Bob: We'll be back
Mark: You're just, there's no one in the labs, they're just a series of rube goldberg machines trying to get everything
Mark: going together. Bob: Just science by algorithm
Bob: Oh sweet Jesus. Mark: Oh sweet, I'm trying to put ammo in here, oh God I'm being ow
Bob: I'll cover you. Mark: ow, ow, ow, ow Bob: I'll cover you, I'll cover you. Mark: I can't move
Mark: AAAHHH. Damn it. Bob: did you die? Mark: I died!
Bob: Oh shit. Mark: Why didn't you cover me? Bob: I was fucking trying. Mark: I was trying too
Mark: Goddamn it I'm all the way out here, I got nothin'
Mark: Damnit all my shit just exploded all over the place!
Bob: You should spawn pretty close to the base. Mark: yeah but all my shit got exploded
Mark: I have to break down this wall with my bare hands to get in (laughing) Bob: (laughs)
Mark: I claw it with my broken fingernails and just desperately trying
Mark: Alright, I'm go-, I need to go get more iron and copper and shit. This is bullshit
Mark: you have fucked me
Mark: you have fuckulated me
Bob: I didn't do anything to you. Don't blame me for your problems. Mark: I blame you anyway
Mark: just because I can
Mark: This copper is out of control
Mark: Alright, ok, I'm slowly, very lagishly coming back
Bob: Well, I'm still assaulting these bases so... Mark: Oh no. Bob: I'll finish, I'll finish what we started
Mark: I, no, I'm coming. I, I want to start this so I wanted to finish it. Bob: this was your idea, that's correct.
Mark: hang on, hang on, hang on, fuck, ok, hang on, I'm just trying to go in one direction, if I just push myself
Mark: In one way the lag will eventually carry me over.
Mark: Ok, let me make it, no, oh shit I need wood
Mark: no I need... Bob: man, I did not have very much ammo with me
Mark: why didn't you make more ammo?
Mark: ok. Bob: cause I don't think I can
Mark: I'm, I'm makin' a shotgun, I'm carving a shotgun out of the trees around me, I'm fashioning it with
Mark: sticks, it's gonna be super effective weapon, just you wait
Mark: ok, alright, on the way
Mark: I'm coming. Bob: I just assaulted two more nests
Bob: and our turrets are both at half health but that's fine
Mark: no, it's fine. Where are you? Bob: not, not, I'm back out in the same direction
Mark: ok, I'm co- I'm comming
Mark: I'm on the way. Bob: did you bring any iron with you? Cause I could really use some more
Mark: I brought 160. Bob: awesome. Mark: I'll make a wood chest and I'll put it in it
Mark: after I get done making a bagillion shotgun shells
Mark: ok, hang on, I'm just cancelling those. Ok, and, blonk, blonk, blonk. Bob: oh I got a chest here.
Mark: well too late. Bob: I already got a chest. Fine. Mark: there we go, oh man this lag is unreal
Mark: (sigh) Bob: it's un fuckin' here you can have your, uh, turret back
Bob: then we'll each have one. Mark: thank you. Bob: took, took a little pinch. Mark: it's ok, it's ok
Mark: alright, do we wanna assault one more base? Is this gonna go well for me? It didn't go well for me last time
Mark: I destinctly remember. Bob: ah, it'll be fine, we just need to put our turrets down more, um, aggressively
Mark: yeah, more preemptively. Bob: and not wait until we're already being overrun
Bob: ah, they're coming, they're coming. Mark: it's only a few. Just don't shoot me. Bob: I'm trying
Mark: alright, I'm gonna put one here, I'm a fill it with, I have no ammo for it. So I'm slowly gonna make ammo
Mark: for it and then it's gonna be good. Bob: I can put some ammo in it for you. Mark: no I got, it's got two magazines
Bob: there you go. Mark: aw it was fine, alright. Bob: here they come. Mark: aw shit, lag, lagging. Bob: oh sweet Jesus
Mark: lagging. Bob: move left, move left, move left. Mark: aaahh, ok, we're fine. I'm gonna move mine in
Bob: move yours up and I'll cover you planning it. Mark: alright, it's gonna be in the middle of the woods
Mark: right, oop, shit. Bob: oh sweet Jesus. Mark: I lagged forward. Bob: ammo, ammo, ammo, ammo
Bob: ammo, ammo, ammo, ammo Mark: I'm tryin, I'm tryin, I'm tryin, I'm tryin. I can't, I'm lagged out. I can't move
Bob: did you die? Mark: oh I'm fine. Bob: you're good. Mark: I'm fine. Bob: ammo, ammo, ammo. Mark: everything's fine. I can't, oh god, it there's ammo in it
Mark: I can't, I'm still moving, oh god the lag's so bad. Bob: the trees, the trees ruined everything
Bob: why trees? Mark: no the trees haven't ruined anything, ok, here they come. Bob: oh god
Mark: I'm, I'm trying to make repair packs to fix up my, my thing. Did you know you can make repair packs and repair things?
Bob: I, I did. I did know that. I think I'm out of stuff to make repair packs though. Mark: it's just a little iron, it ain't no big deal
Mark: ok, so now we can assault this base with confidence. Bob: how the fuck do I make repair packs?
Mark: I got you, I got you boo. Don't worry boo, I got you. Bob: alright, thank you
Mark: you are welcome, ok, now. Bob: ooh, that's a fancy lookin one. Mark: yeah that one's got more artifacts
Bob: ow, ow. Mark: oh man I need to move mine closer, hang on. Bob: yeah we need to get the turrets closer
Mark: got it, ok, it, it's comin in. Turret flyin in. Turret, turret loaded up. Ok turret loaded
Mark: alright we're good. Bob: I'm gonna move mine closer
Mark: now we got it, now we got it, now we got it. Yeah, they're tryin to poop out little larva. Bob: mine is assaulting the base
Mark: yeah, that's the stuff. Bob: yeah, yeah baby. Mark: murdering local wildlife as is our desire?
Mark: I don't know. Shit. I'm still shooting. Bob: ouch. Mark: get out of the way! Bob: ouch, ouch, ouch
Mark: I was just shooting. It was lag shooting, it wasn't me. I can't control myself
Mark: I'm a monster. Bob: (laughs) It's ok Mark, everyone already knew that
Mark: I just can't hold down the button because that's the problem. I think, I think that's what's fucking everything up
Mark: like holding down, ok. Bob: hey we did it man. Mark: we did it! Alright. Bob: I've got 35 alien artifacts
Mark: nice! Now once we get more stuff, that big a base to the norse, n-, north, the big base to the north
Bob: norph? Mark: norpth? Is gonna be next on our bucket list to kill (lisping)
Bob: (lisping) it's gonna be next stop for us. Mark: (lisping) yes us ecoterrorists, we come to an alien
Mark: (lisping) world and we ravage the local population with our science till ever
Mark: (lisping) you'll never see me coming. Eh. Eh. Geh. Bob: that was kinda like nerdy macho man Randy Savage
Mark: I was trying to do, I was trying to do, uh. Bob: you'll never see me comin, brother. Mark: aw shit, everything
Mark: slowed down. I was trying to do nerdy, nerdy um, uh, uh, whatchacallit. The mandarin from Iron Man 3
Bob: oh yeah. Mark:  your, your capitalist society, it's crumbling to ash around you, you'll never see me coming
Mark: something like that. Is that intimidating? Bob: yeah, yeah, yeah. Mark: ok cool, thanks, thanks man
Mark: thank you. Bob: dead on. Mark: thank you. I tried really hard. Alright 147 regular science, how much big science?
Bob: yes. Mark: uh we got 126 science 2. I feel like the science 2 should be making more but I think there's a
Mark: choke hold somewhere in there. Ok. Bob: I think it's short on inserters it looks like
Mark: probably. Bob: it looks like there are just not a lot of inserters going out. Oh I think it's choking up on, uh
Bob: circuit boards too. Mark: no, it's got plenty of circuit boards, there's literally... Bob: no I think it's got too many
Mark: oh I gotcha. Bob: the inserter creators can't place anything because...oh and actually there's...
Mark: oh wait the gear, the gear maker isn't working. Bob: huh. Mark: why is the gear maker not working?
Mark: uhhh... Bob: it can't place anything? Mark: oh it needs more iron! It's, we literally just need more iron
Mark: that's the only thing thats, it's running out of iron, that's it, ok, so I'm going to increase iron output
Mark: over there
Mark: ahh, ok, so this is yeah, this is fine, easy peasy. Taken care of. Bob: look at that back up of copper, damn
Mark: yeah I know, the copper is... Bob: copper for days. Mark: copper is ludicrous right now
Bob: it's out of control copper, it's out of control
Mark: and then make...I'm going to make a fast, another ernaldo to go out here, that is gonna pump out
Mark: way more. Bob: way more...
Mark: oh shit. Bob: more. Mark: it's pumping all of it. Bob: muy more. Mark: so we need more, I need more
Mark: ah shit, I'm outta stone, I lost everything goddamn it! I'm mad, I lost everything. Bob: theres a buncha stone and the chests
Mark: I got it. No, there's a buncha wall in the chests. Bob: do you need brick or stone stone?
Mark: stone stone. Bob: I got some stone I can give you here. Mark: please. Bob: I'm stuck, I'm stuck, hang on
Bob: I'm stuck, alright I'm gonna put it in the top right. Mark: please, ok, thank you, ok, so I just need to
Mark: make more, uh, electric mining drills, why, oh, iron plate, ok, more electric mining drills, and then everything is gonna be kosher
Bob: this is quite the little encampment we got goin on here, you know?
Mark: it's not bad, you know, cou-, from what I assume everyone was probably doubting that we'd ever get to
Mark: this point, but you know, we proved some people wrong, we proved, huh?
Bob: look at the map, at the north pollution. Mark: ah shit. Bob: we don't have a lot of time before we're super...Mark: ah shit
Mark: we have no northern defenses, do we? Bob: no, not even... Mark: literally none. Bob: I got some turrets
Bob: I've got 3, 4 turrets up here by the iron production. And no wall or anything. Mark: I think in the next episode
Mark: we need to refigure our power supplies because that... Bob: so they can be auto fed? Mark:  yeah, they can be auto fed because this situation
Bob: dying constantly? Mark: yeah, eventually we're gonna move to like laser turrets and so we need, like
Mark: reliable power that keeps us safe at night. Bob: nah, whatever, we just need to reconfigure the steam engines
Bob: into a way...and there's a coal patch right down here. We just need to reconfigure the steam engines
Bob: into a way that the coal, like maybe on the right side? Mark: uh huh? Bob: of this body of water
Bob: and then... Mark: ok, yeah. Bob: get some coal, a dedicated coal supply just for the boiler. Mark: yeah
Mark: or is there a coal supply by the big lake to the west or the coal's only here?
Bob: I think there's a coal supply in that direction but there's not one like this one that's like on the water's edge
Mark: ok, yeah. Bob: we can go, we can go look, alright, we're fucking walled in all the way
Mark: nah, I trust ya, I trust ya. I believe ya. Bob: but my tommy gun does. Mark: (laughs)
Mark: I like that reference. That was a good one. The only reason... Bob: uhhh, there's an oil field to the, oh
Bob: that's not the main body of water. Mark: oh yeah, oil! Oil! We don't need... Bob: oil. Mark: we don't need
Mark: steam engines if we have oil, ahhh. Bob: well there's like one little puddle of oil out here, so I don't think that's enough
Mark: there's a big puddle of oil down to the south, do you see that down there? Like a big pool. Bob: uhhhhh...
Mark: or to the north, like north by this coal, like there's even more oil, lots of oil. Bob: oh, ok, well that'll work
Mark: it's in the middle of the forest and I'm lagging my way through. Bob: we just need to do some more deforestation
Mark: yeah. Bob: mass deforestation. Mark: ruin. Bob: get to sweet, sweet crude oil that's beneath all those stupid fucking trees
Mark: yeah fuck those stupid trees and all the animals that live there, just stupid animals. Bob: so maybe we can leave the steam engines as is
Bob: and transition into engines for power. Mark: yeah. Bob: I mean, like, generators, maybe next episode
Mark: maybe, probably. I mean, I, I wouldn't just like, immediately like fuck the steam engines, let's get
Mark: the shit out of here, like we can run everything in the immediate. Bob: leave em in place but, like, just don't
Bob: go through the whole kerfuckity of rekagiggering them and feeding them with coal if we're just gonna switch off to other power
Bob: sources anyway. Mark: yeah that's probably true, yeah. Bob: cause you can pipe oil from, I mean you just need pipes to move oil around
Bob: to refineries and then directly into the, uh, engines probably, right? Mark: yeah, and then we can use
Mark: pipe underground. Bob: oh yes, underground pipe. I've already used some as you saw, expertly employed
Bob: to make sure that my water supply was safe. Mark: (laughing) from, from what exactly? What is your water supply safe from?
Bob: water thieving fucking aliens. Mark: (laughing) that's the, that's the aliens from Enders Game
Bob: what do you mean from what? Mark: I'm ju- I'm hey, I'm, I'm sorry, Bob, again I'm questioning your incredible
Mark: logic and brain power here, I'm sorry, I should know better at this point, you are the glorious leader that we all follow into
Bob: I'm the one who thought of all this shit. Mark: I know! I know you are! It's true, you are the greatest
Mark: ever in the entire world. Like, literally of the two people on this planet, you're the best.
Bob: that's why they call me big boobs Bob
Mark: dude. Do they call you big boobs Bob? And who? Because, again I'm the only other person on this planet
Mark: so that would, that would mean that I call you big boobs Bob. Bob: I uh, I'm actually in a book club with some of the aliens
Bob: and uh they do sometimes, it's not, it's not, you're not invited, sorry. Mark: oh, well, ok, alright
Bob: they told me that, um, they've seen your YouTube videos through space. Mark: uh huh
Mark: yeah. Bob: so stuff, and uh, you're not invited, so... Mark: ok alright, well if I kill all the fuckin aliens and then
Mark: you have no one else to book club with... Bob: I guess you and I would have to have a book club.
Mark: alright, then I'm gonna murder every-, be right back. I'm just gonna lag my way into death
Bob: (laughs) Mark: I die horribly in the middle of nothing, god, ok. Bob: man when you get rid of all these trees, this land is so useful
Mark: yeah, I know. Bob: why do we even have trees? Mark: stupid, we cou- you could have started out in a desert, by em, it would have made things way
Mark: easier, but no, you had to get in the lush forest. Bob: alright, so should I get some pump jacks going?
Mark: yeah I don't even know how to do that. Oh, yes I do. Bob: I'm just gonna craft some pump jacks and see
Bob: what happens. Mark: alright, I believe in you. Bob: also, I think we also need some, um, logistical stuff
Bob: like, pipes, and also... Mark: yeah, I'm gonna work on the oil refinery
Mark: I need, just a little more stone brick and iron. Bob: alright, yeah I'm gonna go get some more iron
Bob: so that I have some iron. Mark: uh huh, oh, there's lots of stone brick in here
Bob: oh my gosh, I just got like 1200 iron. Mark: there's so much iron. Literally, there is. Bob: Jesus Christ
Mark: there is way too much iron. We went overboard on the iron. Bob: it's all good.
Mark: and actually when we get the, uh, plastics in place, which we're getting from this oil, we should do this oil
Mark: also for the plastics but we are going to have, um, whatchamacallits, whatchamadoodads
Mark: uhhh, super electric furnaces. Yeah electric furnaces which means we don't need to feed em with coal anymore
Mark: and then can just double up on the iron, nice. Bob: super-di-duper electric furnaces? Mark: (lisping) super-di-duper
Mark: (lisping) is the technical term for the electrical furnaces, get it right, uh, Bob. Bob: wow, that's cool
Mark: ok then the, I don't know what the... Bob: we can make 1.1K pipes. I don't know if I need that many
Mark: (laughs) how much iron did you grab? Bob: that might be overkill
Mark: (laughing) there is uh, there's other research options that also allow us to handle that stuff better
Mark: but I don't know. Advanced oil processing. That's all I know.
Mark: heavy oil cracking to light oil. What the hell does that mean? What does that mean?
Bob: heavy oil cracking to light oil, obviously
Mark: oh, oh, ok. Bob: it means just... Mark: I get it, I should have known. I'm sorry
Mark: anyway, that's all the time for this episode so I guess we're done here, so thank you everybody
Mark: so much for watching. In the next episode we'll have oil production on our to do list and we will get it done
Mark: real good. So thank you everybody and as always, we'll see you in the next video. Bye-bye
(outtro music)